laurent enfourche son vélo et sort
rapidement son offre une auto à lille à
ce moment le vélo dollar en fait la
voiture
laurent n'a que quelques ecchymoses
la voiture elle a des dommages
importants l'automobiliste ne s'en tire
pas trop mal puisque son assureur
accepte de dédommager
mais une mauvaise surprise attend dans
l'assureur de l'automobiliste lui
réclame les dommages à la voiture les
dommages qu'ils atteignent 5000 $ 2
laurent refuse de payer
mais l'assureur le poursuit aux petites
créances selon le code de la sécurité
routière
un conducteur sortant d'une propriété
privée doit céder le passage à tout
véhicule qui circule sur le chemin et ça
s'applique aussi aux cyclistes
le juge c'est donc laurent responsable
de l'accident et des dommages
le juge le condamne à payer plus de 4800
dollars à l'assureur de l'automobiliste
qui l'a frappé le fin mot de l'histoire
deux roues quatre roues c'est du pareil
au même
on le code de la sécurité routière